Hello, everybody! My name is Markiplier!
And welcome back to Homecoming Starring Markiplier.
Now we just got chased by a horrible monstrosity, or someone that turned INTO a horrible monstrosity.
We're not sure which.
"I dont need to go back to my room. It's easier to stay here, okay?"
Alright!
You stay  around the bloody toilets. I am sure they are fun and free and fancy.
Okay. Hello!
"I used to be a painter. I mean I guess I
still am but.. I haven't made anything in so long."
Aww.. That's kinda sad.
Being robbed of your skill. I mean, isn't the whole situation that these people are kinda in limbo,
They're stuck between life, and death and that's no good?
*Chuckles* Chica, why are you chasing your tail over there? I'm sorry,
Chica- Chica just caught my eye because, she just started chasing her tail randomly,
She never really does that. Oh.
"Why get out of bed if there's nothing you care to do? I should just go back to sleep."
Oh!
And roll over she did.
Man, that sounds like depression symptoms.
And that's no good.
I mean, that would be odd if the people that were stuck in this limbo....
"It doesn't make any difference. Nothing will change anyway. Whats the point?"
That really sounds like depression
Is that why these people are stuck here?
Because they can't...
I don't know. They can't... find the motivation to move forward? The reason?
"I watched the sun rise this morning. I think I'm almost ready... to move up to floor five. It seems better there."
(Surprised) Oh!
Okay!
So some sort of... like...
Manual choice they have to do?
Like, they have to choose to ascend in this world?
Oh!
*Chuckles* It does seem better up here!
Oh this is lovely! <3
It's very warm.. and golden!
"I don't hate it here, to be honest."
Well, don't you have a funky smile?
"There are a lot of things I miss. But then there are a lot I don't."
Okay!
Thanks for being nice and vague!
I really wanted a lot of description here, and you didn't deliver at all.
Okay.
Hello! Who are you?
"He looked so determined when he came through. Do you think he'll succeed? It's possible, right?"
I...I don't know! You're all speaking so vaguely! I have no idea whats going on.
"I'm not here because I'm okay. I'm not okay, and I won't be. I'm just okay with never being okay now."
That's a cryptic way of looking at life, and existence, or non-existence or what ever else you want to call your time here.
Chica's going nuts over there.
Well someone wasn't very hungry.
Hello teddy bear! Again...
Huh.
"Probably lightens the mood."
I don't know! I seem to like all the MBBLLL-Blood downstairs.
"Things could have gone another way, but they didn't. There are no alternate endings in life."
Huh. Well that's fancy!
Well there might be alternate endings in this game! I mean, honestly, who knows?
Oh, are you the gate keeper?
"I've totally accepted what I am. I have nothing deluding me, or holding me back anymore.
Its that great?"
Oh is it people accepting their-
DDDDDD- OH!
"Why don't you become a monster too? You can stay here with us"
UH OH!  SORRY!
"Don't bother trying to escape"
I WILL BOTHER IMMEDIATELY!
*scared laugh*
Hi, okay.
🎵Goooooooooooooooood byyyyyyyee-EEeee🎵
Ha!
AWW!
I didn't... aw god damnit I didn't... awww
You bet. I'll try again.
Is that the first time it's given me a try again? (no)
What am I supposed to do? HELP ME! *talks to girl* HELP ME!
Ohhh...
*Bleep*
*laughing* Jeeez! Nah, it's giving me a try again before but this one happens, happens to be very immediate.
Oh boy, oh boy, oh boy. What do I do?
It's not very clear!
Not very clear!
Oh man that was quite the wicked hay maker.
Cause I gotta get around to get back in to the upstairs in the next area but..
Whoa
Mark! I sense that you're struggling.. Let me help the best way I can.
Uh tha... that... that be great
I'll show you the best path to take. You'll still have to travel it just right, to not be caught. I know you can do it!
...iiing to escape!
What? Fucking to escape? Ducking to escape? Plucking to es- Okay
Oh... Oooooh that is awfully handy
Thank you!
Wait in here? What?! Oooh... *smack* Ooooooooh I didn't know that was a thing you could do.
I mean I was gonna figure it it out but thanks for the conclusion... *mumbles everything else he was gonna say in english*.
What ever...
Take your help and shove it up your butt.
*Makes karate sounds*
K.O.!!!!!!
OH haha god damnit
Well that didn't help at all
*Its tea time!*
Wait no
AHHHHH YEEEEE AHHH YEEE AHHH YEEE
YEEEEEAAAAH!!! Good thing I'm so fast.
Been getting a lot of training in my liiiiiiiiiiife that was too close
No thank you. Okay did I finally make it?
Let me make a savey soov
Alright
I got my save juice all over here.
Lets see whats going on over here.
Helloooooo
Ahh good. I know she's around here somewhere.
*creep mode engaged
Come out, come out, where ever you are, Marki- hello?
"Uh oh..."
Uhhh... "Uh oh?"
"Are you a lingering spirit?"
"Me? No I'm alive... Like you."
"Am I?"
Ye... Yeah.
"I guess it makes sense that you are. The nice lady on the fifth floor said it's hard for lingering spirits to ascend in the hospital."
"I thought you might have been on of the bad ones and you'd figured out how to get up here."
"Nah. I'm a friend. I was sent by your nurse actually. Nurse Hale. My name is Mark."
"Oh! New friends are nice, but I've known her for a long time. She's my best friend!"
"I think you're right about that. She saved your life by calling me here."
"How come?"
"Well.. What you're- what we're doing right now dangerous. We can only out of our for a while, and than we can never go back."
*lovely silence*
Oh...
"I know it must be boring in your body, but Nurse Hale says they should be able to wake you up soon."
"She says that a lot.."
"I know she's trying as hard as she can, though. It just gets so boring. Maybe staying her as a spirit forever wouldn't be bad.."
"You don't want that. I've just met a lot of people in that situation, and trust me- they're not happy."
"hmmm"
*More silence*
"Will you stay and talk to me then? Just for a little while?"
"Of course! Let's go ahead and move to your room though, okay?"
"Okay!"
*says creepily*
And than get back into your bed and shove back into your fricken body!
So tell me about yourself, Sophie.
Uh.. Well before the coma, it was just me and my dad. He was the nicest guy you'd ever meet!
He was a brilliant doctor. He was so good, he inspired people around him to get into the health field too!
He was a good cook, too. He would make me delicious dinners, and every morning he'd make me a different kind of sandwich.
He didnt run out of ideas?
Oh, no. He would find recipes and sometimes just make something up. He'd always make an extra for Jenna, too. He was very nice.
Sounds like he took very good care of you.
Yep! And he will again... When he gets back.
Where is he?
It's kind of a long story.
Well, not like I'm in a hurry to save Tim.
So, how long will I be asleep?
I don't know for sure, Bluebird. I'll be as diligent and quick as I can.
Will I have dreams?
Hmm.. I think you will.
So I'll have nightmares too?
Let's hope not.
Why can't I just go with you?
Your condition is going to get much worse very soon. The only way I can prevent it is to put you to sleep for the time being.
And than you'll wake me up when you can make me all better?
That's right. I'm very close to being able to cure you. I just have to make a trip to a far away place to use a special machine.
Okay..
Don't worry. It'll all be over before you even realize it.
Promise?
It'll be like it never happened.
Something tells that promise was not kept. (no kidding Mark)
Are you ready?
Yes Sir. I'm ready.
Very good.
Screw being in a hospital!
Right now our time is done.. but I will be the sun.
Aww. I promise.
*Markiplier thinks of all of the good times he had with his friends in horror games*
*remembers Tiny Box time and how adorable he was*
Did- Did he put her to sleep right then and there?
That's something we'd say whenever Daddy had to leave. The sun sets everyday, but no matter what happens, it always comes back.
I see. And so you're still waiting on him to come back, huh?
Yeah. I know it's been a long time, but it's not his fault. He must have just ended up needing more time to find the cure.
Well I hope he finds his way back to you soon. If he's not quick enough, Nurse Hale might just have you better before he gets here...
Hmm.. maybe. She's the nicest lady I know, but I don't think the regular doctors can cure me. Daddy said it was something really advanced.
One way or another, they're gonna make you better. Until then, you need to stay put, okay? Even when it's kinda boring.
Okay. I will.
Mark?
Yeah?
Will you come back and see me sometime? Like this again, so we can talk?
To be honest.. I don't have much time left to spend as a spirit. A couple hours, maybe.
But I'll tell you what.. as soon as I take care of little issue back home, I'll spend as much of that time as i can with you. Okay?
Okay! You have to be the sun!
Heh. I will. It was nice to meet you.
You too!
Well how will I know exactly how much time I have left?
I mean, I'm all for visiting you, but.. I don't know if i have that much time to go
Welcome back.
Hiiiiiiiiiii!
Must've been a little crazy, huh?
Yeah. It was a lot.. sadder than I expected. Scary or dangerous I'm used to by now, but I feel bad for all the lingering spirits...
Don't worry too much about them. They've only recently passed. Time is the best- and only- medicine for them. They'll pull out of it.
Also, you may have found yourself to be a little moody as you ascended. The overall atmosphere of an area is determined by its residents
Ezzzz
This can affect how things look, as well as alter the mood of others who pass through. Did you notice a theme as you made your way?
Yeah. It got brighter AS I WENT UP!
Anyways, there's good news!
Oh yeah?
It worked! Sophie's vitals looked so much better right away! I came down here, knowing you'd talked to her.
That's great! She's such a sweet kid.
We're gonna get her better. I won't rest a second until we do. Thank you so much for your help.
I'm just happy that I was able to.
Honestly, I'm a little jealous. I'm so fasinated with all this spiritual stuff...
SCREW MODERN MEDICINE, GET ME INTO SPIRITUALITY!
...but I don't really like, I don't really get to experience it like you do.
Oh well.
Say uhh... What's the deal with Sophie's dad? She says he's away to research or something.
Yeah, that was the last she heard before she fell into a coma. He's been missing for as long as she's been in the coma.
Unfortunately, he is assumed to have passed. It's ashame too. He was a kind, brilliant man. He'd have her cured I bet...
Do you know what caused the coma?
We're not exactly sure, no. We figure it was most likely a side effect fo the stress caused by her condition.
Hmm... Alright yeah because it's NOT! It's done did by her dad...
Well, I guess I should head home and take care of matters there, but I'll be back.
I actually promised to spend more time with Sophie.
Heh, you're very kind.
Even though you're gonna get trapped in the spirit world, and your body's gonna wither away and die.
*looks smugly at the camera* Oh well.
If you don't mind my asking.. What is it that you have to take care of back home? I feel that I owe you.
Well I've got a living weird creature of a BOX!
It's cute and adorable but uh-  it talks and moves on its own!
Very strange..
Uh- It's being chased by a.. body morphing, shapeshifting demon.
*laughing* No! Not at all!
You don't owe me a thing, and I don't want you to get involved with thi- I WOULD!
If someone's offering help to defeat a shape-shifting demon to rescue my little biscuit,
I would sure as hell recruit them!
It's the demon- the same one that kicked me out of my body the first time.
He's got a fake body, and is in my house.
Oh, this is great!
It doesn't sound great!
Say what? That's not the way I would describe it.
I mean, not the demon. But I can help you out after all!
Believe it or not, we can banish the demons from the safety of this creepy basement!
AW! OGOSH! I'm gonna uh- raise up my uh, questioning finger.
I'm gonna press X to doubt on that one.
Oh yeah?
In the time it would take you to drive home, I could teach you to project your spirit to a remote location.
You could summon your helpers again.
Oh!
You know- the monsters you used to get your body back the first time.
A living spirit can do a lot of great things if
its wielder knows how.
So it won't actually be here- be there?
I don't want to spend my remaining time
to be a wandering spirit
Mmm, your body would be here, but your spirit there. It would cost some of your remaining time, yes.
But I can make it so you can speak with Sophie
from your body so that won't be an issue
other than people thinking you're
talking yours- How many superpowers do you have, lady?
This kinda sucks you know.
What's that?
You're basically turning me into a superhero but I can only use all these powers for a couple hours.
Ha I guess you're riiight. Yeaah...
So you ready?
Okay
Lets do it.
Yeah okay I- I'm waggling the finger of
doubt pretty hard over here but let's do it.
Alright. And so once again, nurse hail taught
markiplier how to tame his natural
talent for Supernatural techniques. It
would attack the demon from afar using
his dreamt up allies. Okay! Alright! Save game? Suuure! Me lovie to save game.
Oooh! Hellooo.
Who is you?
Troops! We meet again.
Did you let your body get snatched again?
Ha! What an idiot.
Buttstabber, you son-of-a-bitch
I don't want to hear it right now. Tim may
be in trouble, so it's our mission to
corner that demon to destroy it once and for all.
Wait what? It's the third game dinkus damnit! We have to finish this. Wait so why
are you guys trying to fight the dem-
What? Blood monster you're kinda slow but
you're all icky and bloody, that's gotta
be worth something right? Butt stabber I'm
not sure I can trust you but I don't
have a choice.
You're fast and deadly, but you're the
wild card i'll have to use you carefully
these words I'm saying straight to your
face so you understand how much of a
threat i think you is. Blind Wolf you're
a Wolf. and you're blind. you can see for
crap but your have decent hearing and a
great sense of smell I'll have to make use of that
outside of the power I used to summon
you guys i can probably seal a door shut and
and warp myself
OH this is me
OH I didn't know that was me,
Ohhhhhh
*sudden realization
ok i will scare the demon away from my
room i will station you throughout the
house strategically todrive the demon to
the basement where I'll be waiting
any questions
yeah what if...
good question
unfortunately we don't have time for an answer.
OKAY!!! and away we go
first of all which room should I block
off I should choose the one that is
potentially the most problematic
well I don't know block off i think the
kitchen would 'cus the kitchen... the bathroom
might also be a bad one the library you
can loop around
(MARKIMOO'S FACE THOUGH XD)
Imma go with the bathroom yeah I should probabl
is off now where should have the blind
wolf hide
Markimoo's head: I should do this but than I can't portect that and this go into ruins.
I should have put the butt stabber in
the bathroom
shit umm
(Also this is a good time to soak in all of markimoo's super powers)
(More of dat face)
The Studio???
The library.
blood orc
station him in the...
Tudio
(This that an actual thing mark?)
Okay
I don't know how
I'm not a
hundred percent sure how this is gonna
work
ah hello hey it me you again
yep hit me (o shit waddup) it dat boi. it me. ghost boy. are you back in that form
I've learned a lot including out to
destroy you once and for all
you may as well give up now ok alright
bye then
good job giving up
(Deep hallway)
Ha ha ha ha ha
(Amnesia maybe?)
Oh
kooky haha haha
you've been butt stabbed Oh you got
stabbed in the butt somehow i did this
correctly haha ok so you done did been
stabbed in but alright so
whoa-oh
awww
unfortunately his lack of thumbs proved
to be a bigger problem than his lack of
sight unable to climb the bookshelf that
the demon even if it could the initial
excitement smelling blood dissolve one
didn't notice the skinwalker stink in
the air by the time the oversized
figured that was enough time left
advanced demon sure
ok so that was wrong ok so
ah ok so let's do something else I'm
gonna block off the library because that
seems that seems to be a problem
the blind wolves should hide in the
bathroom like right away
blood or should be in the studio and
then bought stabbed her in the kitchen
because the kitchen butt stabbed and
worked quite well I actually really like
this by the way I didn't mention that
before this is a really cool mechanic
that I've never seen in an RPG Maker
game that's really awesome
ok let's see how this works come on get
him arf ohh it's blind course it is
alright fine wait and see how this plays
out we don't know how it's gonna
complete itself
gotcha ok stabbed in the butt first so
that's an important thing to be stabbed
in the butt first then maybe if i have
the butt stabber
yeah but the butt stabber wouldn't be hiding
would it maybe it would be the butt
stabber the bathroom seems like the
good thing there and too slow on a lark
notice the blood remind himself he
decided that the demon must have been
his long-lost brother
oh it's a fwiend hahahahaha
surely there's a better method okay i
think i got it i think i got it i think
i got in this time in the first game the
but stabber was in the bathroom
and i'm pretty sure that's where I'd
want me to put them unless it's throwing
me for a loop here which one want to
close
(everyone type in the comments now on what he should do.)
probably the library
it seems that the library's problem
because then he would just be able to
run around all the time so the library
is closed off
blind wolf
in the kitchen the blood orc in the
studio and the butt stabber in the
bathroom and that should give me the
best opportunity to kill him dead if
that is in fact to my goal so I'm gonna
get him good
watch this alright so ah oh it's so
secret huh
it's subsea oh wait where you didn't
stab them in the by he didn't stab them
in the but oh well
so what is key forward
ok so injured first which is good ? i'm
not a percent sure but i'm going to
assume and then back to the studio to be
chased down to the basement
here we go our blood no it's blood it's
been a long lost brother
no no okay I know what the method is now
I know the method is now I know what it
is now I know what it must be because my
assumption was wrong i'm not trying to
kill him
I'm just trying to chase some into the
basement so
that doggie go in the studio the blood
orchid in the kitchen and then the butt
Stabber in the bathroom and that means
that no one will actually be able to
hurt him the blood orc will not be
stupid get a friend and then we'll be
able to go down to basement because
apparently that's where we want to
change them do about stabbing do your
thing
very good alright so he's there then the
blood or should do something different
in the kitchen then the wolf did too
slow
that's the thing okay yeah i'll not
before being smeared with blood first is
that good at me all that means that the
wolf is going to be able to smell the
blood
oh ok that's good that's a good thing
that means that we're gonna it's gonna
smell the blood
notice the scent of blood near God it I
got it
that's good that's good that's good
right there that's good
ok yes beautiful demon was led the
basement with nowhere else to turn mark
was waiting to finish the encounter
you bet it hello it's over
oh well then this again really don't
know how he knew that was there i guess
he was going for the switch or do i need
to chase you
why couldn't you just give up because
i'm mark about wow i'm not i'm not fast
and come back here
wait hang on
yeah I am I did I need please come back
oh I've got you cornered now deja vu huh
said last time descended with you giving
up of your own volition this time you
don't have a choice
where's Tim on the other side of this
wall my guess he jumped down maybe
should go save him up or not just yet
not until I'm finished with you so you
really learned how to get rid of me then
that's right it's been a fun ride but
this is where you get off and not in the
good way
well who haha do it then I don't have
any tricks up my sleeve
I don't have anything oh I don't have
anything to fight back with
(mark your scaring me)
haha putting on that sad voice really
you're gonna try sympathy after
everything we've been through
I'm sorry Sophie did you say Sophie not
now okay come on now don't know
come on come on doesn't matter do what
you have to do now because I met a
sophie not an hour ago what are the not
the same one you didn't mean this Sophie
today she's in a coma
oh how do you know Sophie know how do
you know Sophie kind of a weird story
but if i had met her I wouldn't know how
to send you away for good
that right makes sense she probably
hates me for what I did what did you do
to her
do you go around this town harassing
everyone so this is her father
no I broke my promise I failed
are you your Sophie's dad I don't know
what that I deserve that title but yes I
am her father is crazy what are the odds
that it was you pursuing me all this
time did she not send you to banish me
what know she's waiting for you she said
you put her into a coma she's just not
mad at me
what was your plan tell me yeah I'd like
to hear this one
ok i'm a gifted doctor from Nicaragua I
am I was a single father a good father i
believe as fate would have it so he was
diagnosed with an incurable illness but
I wasn't gonna take incurable as an
answer so yes I induced coma to suspend
the illness left to use a friends lab in
another country with the tech and
resources that i needed i had a system
in place to where the authorities would
be notified of Sophie's whereabouts if
something were to happen to me was way
something happened yes you can infer i
became a lingering spirit I refuse the
next world because I wasn't finished in
this one I went through with my research
but it took much longer without a body
at the time I had learned how to
commandeer one I had to get the things I
needed because i couldn't order them
it took me years but I did accomplish my
goal i found the cure i came back to
this town the town where Sophia was
hospitalized
I visited her I don't think she is aware
that I was there since then though her
spirit has been more active I could
sense it
I awakened something in her and that
drove me even more to save her
unfortunately also draw me closer to
becoming a malevolent spirit every
setback whittled away a bit of my
humanity if I even have that I don't
think any other spirit in the hospital
had reached the top level where she'd
stays since you've been admitted
while i was there one of the spirits
taught me how to take a living body and
use it as my own
Taught me what would happen to my host you
ask what the odds were that's it's been
me following you
well it's really not that far-fetched
notion
I watched big houses in town and waited
for a perfect subject to move in before
long there you were you had the money I
needed didn't order the supplies you had
excellent hand-eye coordination for the
surgery so I took your body while you
were weak. you know the rest I suppose
so all those boxes out there are the
supplies you need to save her. that's what
the stuff was for yes but it doesn't
matter now
his body is too twitchy I wouldn't go
near with it
you almost ran me outside my body
forever you know what's not proud to
have I been seeing myself in seven years
older just became careless
I'm sorry I am sorry
the funny thing is you've been studying
me all this time you've learned my voice
and mannerisms in history but you didn't
see my kindness i guess you just explain
the situation to be from the start I
would have helped you
I just got reckless I shouldn't have
wasn't thinking clearly and I still
don't trust you i want to put that on
record for all you I don't trust this!! (YOU TELL HIM MARKIMOO!!!)
son-of-a-bitch as far as I can throw him
I could probably throw not far she's a
great kid isn't she she seems very nice
do you think how much time do you have
left to be outside your body not enough
maybe 20 minutes
I see
but I know a girl who i believe would be
happy to participate in saving Sophie
really ah mark help the spirit out the
whole as well as tiny box Tim spirit
collected the supplies they needed and
headed to the hospital
mark return to his body and Connor's
hell up she informed him that giving
your body to the spirit voluntarily
means that she cannot take it back
without permission if he chose to he can
keep her body but she trusted him I do
not I do not
she said if he was the same doctor she
knew all those years ago then she would
she knew he'd do the right thing
the surgery was prepped and nurse hail
made sure there were no interruptions as
per the doctor's request she also
learned Sophie spirit into a state of
sleep he knew had become too emotional
to focus if Sophie were awake and he
didn't want her to remember this way
anyway
exhale gave her body to him and the
procedure began.
(Mark your not ruining the mood anymore :D)
Sophie's father worked diligently and meticulously this was the
fruition of a plan he dreamt up seven
years ago all of his research paid off
every step of the way he knew exactly
what to do he had planned for every
contingency
he was ready there was one thing he
didn't know how to handle however none
of his tests for sacramental preparation could
have read him for what happened as he
finished up the procedure his daughter
spirit being an especially strong one
pulled itself back from unconsciousness
what's what are you doing
Sophie you can hear me I've been talking
to you for so long
Sophie I i know this is strange but this
is daddy I'm borrowing this body
daddy?!
Whoa
you're going to be all better now you
fixed me I knew you would
and in that moment Sophie's father had
finally resolve the situation that had
cursed him to be a lingering spirit in
the first place he had achieved true
closure
you never gave up all this time of
course not
you said you would be the Sun so I knew
you'd be back in doing so he received an
opportunity that few lingering spirits
achieve he was given a second chance to
move on but he had to make up his mind
right away
I'm sorry that it took me so long
Bluebird I'm so sorry don't be sorry it
doesn't matter all that matters is that
were together and again now I can't stay
with you I have to give this body back
and I don't have one anymore so I can't stay.
what you can stay you have to. I caged
my bluebird once and left her for far
too long
I won't have you spending your time
trying to reach me waiting on me again I
have to go now or stay forever
I don't know what's ahead but I know
it's not here this is the perfect ending
to my story here
no it's not fair you have to take care
of me
you have to make a new sandwich for me
you only a lot of them. I've kept my
final promise I have to go now Bluebird.
fine
our time is for now is done but...
tell jen
and mark i will never forget them
I know they'll make sure you're cared
for. Daddy I said our time now is done
you have to i love you Sophie I love you
more than anything
I have every second since i first held
you for every second I've been gone. I
love you to please our time for now is. I
will always love you. aww
(Markimoo didn't ruin the mood)
in case you didn't get that that was
like he wouldn't say the other half of
that thing where he will always be the
son
Sophie recovered from a coma and her
condition was completely cured she began
physical therapy and improve faster than
expected
there was no denying that she was strong
spirited her father having found solace
and finally being able to keep his
promise was unbounded the physical world
his spirit was able to move on to
whatever might come next
there's hale woke up from her first
spiritual adventure became the first
person to hear Sophie's voice truly hear
it in seven long years mark plan a party
that would trump is original not only
because it would be bigger but because
it was a true celebration of closure the
demon was at peace
well damn that was much different than I
expected it to be
I mean obviously it was you know kind of
similar in the other games but it was
just the story took a different turn
than I thought it would
i mean when i first heard that like all
the demon was the father.the whole time
the the the father that you introduced
in this game and only this game
ok as you but know that really did that
connected that did that landed pretty
well I mean it seemed like it could have
could have gone a few different ways but
that landed pretty darn well I'm I'm
pleasantly surprised by that excited for
five nights at freddies 19? this time
it's super mega personal top of the
morn- evening to ya laddie I'm having a good time
are ya? are ya? oh yeah are you sure about that
I brought Zoo race for the after Party... ITS JAN TRON. JAN tron
I'm the real wade I swear
okay well he's got it
that is when all together and maybe it
was for the better
how cool is that gotta  to
provide some foreshadowing in the second
game long before this whole plot was
starting to unravel I'm important i
don't remember that at all
I trust this weight more yeah I seen
that video where you played Captain
Falcon that's how come you was able to
falcon punch me in the canopy
up but for real you got anything ok that
goodbye
AWOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOO
thanks Puppy
AWOOOOOO
appreciate it didn't I hear you could
you did real good
I don't know why you even invited me if
I'm not allowed to stab butts
wat eve is life without stab butting. I promise
not to kidnapp anyone at your little
party you're the only person who
actually paid me for my work
even to this day happen
wow you're not really intimidating in
the proper lighting. you think i'm cute
Oh God alright yeah those are the
developers of there
hi mark i guess now would be a lot
easier for us to visit each other with
me being a real body
jenna says I can live with her from now
and stay as long as I want
she says you made this possible so thank
you so much that's up the kind nurse
i'll have you know many of the lingering
spirits in the hospital were inspired by
Sophie's father
it won't happen overnight but in time
they will find peace your actions were a
catalyst for that I can never thank you
enough
and this tiny about him you did mark
you're my hero
ok thanks that's it then medium box Mike
still done that much to have a
conversation
nice thanks again for playing our game
it really means a lot to us you can just
ignore John whoring himself out to you
but don't really because you know the
starving artist saying anyone going to
get the werecat now okay
hello John here the guy who typed the
words you're reading right now she's
jerilyn in case you forgot if you like
the sound RAC i wrote for this game
search for unicorn whole on bandcamp and
you can download it i even did some real
instrument remixes of some songs they
sound pretty ratified to say so and i
totally just did
doesn't sound too commercial it i mean
it's free anyway thanks for playing
maybe one day we'll come up with a fresh
idea for you
this idea was fantastic thank you so
much for making this game
thank you so much for making the music
and thank you so much for at putting an
interesting story in and I have to go
back and check to see what the reference
in the second game was to this one
because i want to know how Wayne could
have possibly done something that cool
so thank you everybody so much for
watching I really hope you enjoyed this
adventure if you got another fan game
you want me to play let me know down in
the comments below and thanks again for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video bye bye